après les championnats du monde en 2015
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueille à
partir d'aujourd'hui les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste l'équipe
de france a décidé de miser sur une
nouvelle génération après le fiasco djo
cet été sur place michael et demi
d'euros et patrick jacq de zx lune la
cérémonie d'ouverture vient tout juste
de se terminer
effectivement wilfried la cérémonie
d'ouverture vient de se terminer ici au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
la duré une vingtaine de minutes une
trentaine d'enfants de saint quentin en
yvelines ont défilé sur la piste avec
des drapeaux des pays présents ici pour
les championnats d'europe il a également
eu les discours des officiels avec
notamment michel auger le président de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
au niveau de l'ambiance on attend entre
2000 et 2500 personnes ici au vélodrome
en semaine et puis de 3500 le week-end
autant dire que ça ne fera pas le plein
mais le vélodrome devrait être bien
garni tout de même sur la piste 28
nations et puis de 270 coureurs sont
présents ici au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on a pu
notamment voir les cyclistes belges les
cyclistes espagnols et la grande
bretagne
et bien sûr les pays bas pour la france
on est en opération reconquête
exit françois pervis grégory baugé et
michael d'almeida
tous les trois ont été exclus par la
fédération suite à leur comportement à
rio l'été dernier
par contre les nouvelles têtes d'affiché
seront quand à l'as far qui habite saint
quentin en yvelines et qui a 25 ans il
aurait également l'endurance benjamin
thomas 21 ans
au niveau des objectifs six médailles
d'or sont espérés par l'équipe de france
merci michael et nous suivrons
régulièrement cette actualité à des
championnats sur piste championnats
d'europe ce sera notamment à la
thématique et du prochain si on parlait
sport à l'antenne dès ce jeudi 19h30
émission également avoir à la demande
sur notre site internet